cientos de familias argentinas lo
perdieron todo ropa recuerdos comida
elementos de trabajo todo se lo llevó el
fuego la amenaza se veía lejana pero los
focos de incendio empezaron a
multiplicarse y rápidamente consumieron
cientos de casas en la provincia de
chubut
en la llamada comarca andina que reúne a
las provincias de río negro y chubut
los focos siguen activos en el último
reporte de incendios del ministerio de
ambiente de argentina otras provincias
también son víctimas de las llamas
muchos focos lograron ser controlados el
miércoles gracias a las lluvias pero el
jueves el viento volvió a soplar y las
llamas que resurgieron arrasaron con la
poca vegetación que había sobrevivido
según el diario clarín los presuntos
autores de los siete focos de incendio
en la comarca andina son tres personas
que integran agrupaciones militares
mapuche radicalizadas el ministro de
ambiente presentó una denuncia penal ya
que asegura se trata de una situación
que fue planificada está llegando un
cuerpo de peritos de la policía federal
de argentina solicitado por la justicia
para que haga un relevamiento y pueda
detectar material combustible lo que
daría cuenta de la intencionalidad de
los focos ígneos las previsiones para
este viernes apuntan a condiciones
meteorológicas favorables sin embargo se
espera un aumento de las temperaturas el
fin de semana